today on the matt walsh show democrats
the media and many public school
teachers themselves are now
in response to the coronavirus in effect
arguing that public school is
inessential and
expendable and although i disagree with
their take on the chronovirus i agree
with them
on this point that public school is an
essential and i think we should take
them at their word
actually also five headlines including
kanye's powerful pro-life
plea and in our daily cancellation we'll
discuss whether a black woman doing
irish dance
should get an exemption from the
cultural appropriation
charge or should everybody be held to
the same cultural appropriation standard
or
should we just do away with the whole
concept of cultural appropriation
because the concept is itself
uh absurd stupid insane and many other
uh things as well we'll talk about all
that coming up but first we'll start
here an article
in our in the new york times really
captures
the heroism and courage of our sainted
public school teachers
this is the article written by a public
school teacher named rebecca martinson
and uh it says i won't return to the
classroom and you shouldn't ask me to
please don't make me risk getting kova
19 to teach your child
as i said just incredible courage and
heroism on display there
from from rebecca martinson
let's read a little bit of this she says
every day when i walk into work as a
public school teacher
i am prepared to take a bullet to save a
child in the age of school shootings
that's what the job requires but asking
me to return to the classroom amid a
pandemic
and expose myself and my family to covet
19 is like asking me to take that bullet
home to my own family i won't do it
and you shouldn't want me to okay so she
claims that she would
happily jump in front of a bullet
but she won't go to work when there's
a pandemic that poses almost
no risk risk to children and only a very
moderate risk to
middle-aged adults okay
i became an educator after a career as a
nurse i teach medical science and
introduction to nursing to 11th and 12th
graders at a regional skills center
that serves students from 22 different
high schools in 13 different school
districts
my school district and school haven't
ruled out asking us to return in person
to in-person teaching in the fall as
careful and proactive as the
administration has been when it comes to
exploring plans to return to the
classroom
nothing i have heard reassures me that i
can safely teach in person now she
doesn't say
what she would need to hear that
reassures her that she can
to reassure that she can safely teach in
person i guess what she needs to hear
is that the virus has gone away or or
that there's a cure
if there's a vaccine or something but
you know as i've been saying now for for
a while it's there's no guarantee that
this virus will ever go away
there's no guarantee that there will
ever be a vaccine that's
even close to 100 percent effective you
know we keep reading headlines about how
there's
they're working on a vaccine they're
making progress maybe they are maybe
they aren't
um but we're we're still
really far away from from a vaccine that
that we know actually works
so so what is she what is she saying
exactly
is she saying that she doesn't want to
go back to teaching
until there's a vaccine no matter how
long that takes
let's say hypothetically it takes two
years to have a
an effective vaccine on the market she's
saying she we should shut down schools
for two years
well she doesn't say that exactly but
that but this is reading this entire
article
and many other articles making this this
this case that we shouldn't open schools
up
the one thing that's almost always
missing
is a suggestion
for another plan so we get a lot of
complaints about the plan of opening up
schools
but none of these people will ever say
what they think we should do
all they will say is i don't like that
i'm going to complain and whine about
that
but in terms of what we should be doing
well that i can't say or at least i
won't say
because they know how crazy and
paranoid and selfish it would sound if
they said yes i think we should keep
schools closed down indefinitely even if
it's for two or three years
we should just forfeit an entire
generation of kids we should forfeit
their education
um because i'm i'm afraid of the virus
they don't want to come out and say that
but that is apparently what they really
think
uh let's see she says if i'm asked to
return to the classroom as the pandemic
rages i will have to walk away
as deeply as i love teaching i will not
risk spreading this virus in a way that
could hurt a child or a family member of
a child
while children make up a small
proportion of u.s coronavirus cases and
they are less likely to become seriously
ill than adults
the virus might be linked to
multi-system inflammatory system
syndrome in children plus many of my
students struggle with poverty or from
multi-generational households
i will not risk passing a virus to them
that they might
pass to their vulnerable loved ones i
won't do it
it isn't fair to ask teachers to buy
school supplies we aren't the government
but we do it anyway
it isn't fair to ask us to stop a bullet
we aren't soldiers but we go to work
every day knowing
that if there's a school shooting we
will die protecting our students
but this is where i draw the line it
isn't fair to ask me to be a part of a
massive
unnecessary science experiment i am not
a human research subject
i will not do it okay uh so that's a
little
sample of that now first of all for the
record
uh no teacher anywhere
has ever been asked to stop a bullet
that is melodramatic nonsense and we get
this kind of thing a lot from teachers
constantly making these
self-aggrandizing exaggerations
obviously there is no school system
anywhere
that tells teachers to dive in front of
live bullets
that's that's not happening that is not
the lockdown procedure at any school
where the teachers are required to be
human shields yes
some teachers have died in school
shootings and some have chosen to be
heroic and
sacrifice themselves there have been
cases of that we honor
the teachers that do that that is they
really are heroes there's absolutely no
exaggerating there i mean that's that is
that is heroism um
but a person choosing to be your to be a
hero
isn't the same as asking every teacher
to be a hero
part of the whole point of being a hero
in fact is that you're doing what you're
not asked to do
you're going well above and beyond what
you've been asked to do you're going
beyond the call of duty
um oh and by the way we don't ask
soldiers to drop to
to jump in front of bullets either i
won't jump in front of a bullet i'm not
a soldier well
we don't tell soldiers to do that either
we ask them to kill the bad guys
but they aren't required to dive in the
line of fire on purpose again
some do heroically and those are the
ones we rightfully
reward with the the you know
posthumously with the medal of honor and
other honors as well
um but they aren't asked to and and that
is a
that's a distinction that really matters
because this is a character as a
mischaracterization
a kind of hyperbole that's meant to
emotionally manipulate we're meant to
see teachers as
literal martyrs who are always asked and
required to be superheroes
and i guess the idea is now they're fed
up and we and they've had enough and
we've asked too much of them in their
drawing line that's the idea that's how
it's being presented
and it's just not true and by the way
i'm sorry i i don't
the idea this woman i don't know
anything about her i'm sure she's
perfectly nice woman but
the idea that that she her claim that
she would
she would willingly jump in front of a
bullet for her for
for her students but she won't go to
school during coronavirus
i i don't buy that i'm sorry i don't buy
it on one hand
you're claiming that you you will
sacrifice your very lives for your kids
and for the sake of education
but you're too scared to go teach during
chronovirus don't buy it
not true and don't try to pass this off
oh no i'm not worried about myself
i'm worried about passing this on to the
kids oh baloney
that's not it at all kids we'll show you
the numbers here in a minute
uh but as this woman well knows and she
briefly mentions and then moves on from
um kids only very rarely contract this
and even more rarely
is it fatal for them let's go to the in
fact we went over this last week
the comparison between how
covet affects especially kids as
compared to the flu but let's look at
this chart from the cdc
and you see the total death counts and
this really puts things into perspective
okay as of july 15th there had been
around 120
000 coveted deaths 31
of those deaths were kids aged 0 to 14.
that's about .03 of the total
the flu killed three times
as many kids in that age rage in that
same amount of time now
if you look up um if you if you look up
the age bar you see the vast majority of
deaths
are in the 75 and up bracket
and a great preponderance of those
deaths were in nursing homes and were
due
oftentimes to horrible policy decisions
made by people like andrew cuomo
the 65 and up bracket accounts for you
know you add that up
so you've got 75 and up bracket that's
where most of the deaths are
if you go down to 65 and up so
retirement age on
up that's going to be almost 100 000
deaths right there
so 65 and up that's almost all of the
deaths that's 80 to 85 percent
of the deaths most teachers are going to
be in the 35 to 44 range
uh the average age of a teacher in
america is i think of 41. i looked it up
last week i'll look up a guy but it goes
41 is the average age of a teacher
so they account for um and by they i
mean that entire age group accounts for
less than two percent of all coveted
deaths
the numbers there are pretty clear and
we'll talk more about
the numbers in just a second but first
uh i want to tell you about
lifelock you know we've all these
these uh these scams these internet
scams just get
more you get clever and clever as as
each passing day goes by the scammers
you know this is this is what they do
they they're they're scumbags and this
is how they've chosen to
make a living and uh and so they're good
at it it's sad that cyber criminals are
taking advantage of the chronovirus
pandemic
you know they've sent malware to um scam
people
trying to learn about cures for the
disease they've conducted phishing
attacks device counterfeit online
pharmacies
like i said very very a lot of ingenuity
goes into being a scamming scumbag
and they also focused on the economic
stimulus by creating fake
banking websites as well um and you
think about all this stuff and all these
people that are out there to steal your
information steal your identity that's
why
uh you need to get lifelock lifelock
detects a wide range of identity threats
like your social security number being
on sale on the dark web that's the kind
of thing you're not going to be able to
see for yourself
if you don't have something like
lifelock looking out for you if they
detect your information has potentially
been compromised
they'll send you an alert and if you
become a victim god forbid of identity
theft
lifelock can help you restore your
identity easier than you could do on
your own no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses
but lifelock can see threats that you
might miss on your own join now and save
up to 25 percent off your first year go
to lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walls for 25
off okay so um we
just we're just going through the
numbers here and and you know they're
very clear
we have plenty of data at this point to
make some determinations
uh one of which is that
kovid is not even close to a significant
threat to children
they're very unlikely to spread it very
unlikely to contract it
even more unlikely to die from it and
before you get into the well even one
death is too much are you saying that
you know 30 deaths is okay with you um
no
no no death is okay with me if it if it
were up to me and i could
make a make the decision of course i
would i wouldn't want to see anyone die
at all obviously every death is a
tragedy especially when it's a child
but you can't argue that
okay you can't argue for shutting down
schools
on the basis of the threat it poses to
children because of covid
and then justify it by saying even one
death is too much
you cannot do that if you haven't
also argued for shutting schools down
during flu season
which is a disease again that kills
three times as many children this is an
inescapable logical conclusion if you're
if if at least part of your reason for
wanting to shut down schools
is that it's killed you know um
uh you know a few a few dozen children
in
school aged children if that's even part
of your reason
then you should have been advocating for
shutting down schools during flu season
and probably you haven't
now yes you have isolated cases when
when the flu season gets really bad or
hits a particular
area really hard you have isolated cases
around the country every once in a while
where a school system shuts down
temporarily
but something like this where we shut
down the schools
indefinitely across the entire country
50 million kids no longer going to
school
we've never done anything even close to
that for the flu
even though for the third time and i'm
going to keep saying it the flu
is a much much much greater threat
to children than covid even with a
vaccine
still is and i think we have to keep
emphasizing this because
there's no getting around it if you're
someone advocating for shutting schools
down
and you haven't advocated it for the flu
it doesn't make any sense you're being a
hypocrite and you know it
you know it you know your position
doesn't make any sense
uh now you know someone on twitter and
and
of course we also acknowledge though
that that this is
uh we're talking about the threat it
poses to kids
and the reason i'm emphasizing that
because it's because
that's the emphasis we're getting from
the media and from
a lot of school teachers and people that
are advocating for shutting schools down
yes they're also saying it's a threat to
adults but what they're emphasizing is
the threat to kids and they're saying
that we cannot put our kids in harm's
way they're using the kids
as the excuse and if you're doing that
then we have just you have just
then the flu is going to enter the chat
because that is a very relevant aspect
of this
now it is substantially more dangerous
to adults than to kids that's true
um it's still not fatal to well over 99
of adults who are likely to be working
in schools um
yes any adult whose retirement age are
over
should probably just retire but if
you're 30 35 40
you'll probably be okay i'm 34 myself
i haven't gotten covered yet as far as i
know um
but i probably will eventually you know
somebody on twitter said to me today
uh you know watch what happens to you
when you get it then you'll be sorry for
saying all this
and and i said yeah i probably will get
it you're right
it's probably going to be endemic like
the flu i've had the flu
had it recently wasn't fun um
and yes i'll probably get this too
eventually so will you whoever you are
out there watching this
i hate to tell you you're probably going
to get coronavirus eventually if you
haven't already
doesn't mean i want to doesn't mean i'm
going out to try to infect myself i'm
not going to a
coronavirus party to intentionally
infect myself like they used to do with
the
uh chickenpox parties and stuff um
i'm not doing that but i probably will
get it
the point is i'm going to have to
function in society
in spite of that risk
and society is going to have to function
in spite of that risk
one way or another eventually we're all
going to have to just figure out how to
continue on with our lives
even knowing that this threat this risk
is out there
because what's probably going to happen
is that the chronovirus is going to
become
one of the many threats that we all face
as we go about our daily lives
one of the many things that could kill
us as we go about our daily lives
one of the many things that eventually
will kill us because we're all going to
die
for the umpteenth time that doesn't mean
that we're okay with it or we're
nihilistic or we're saying oh just take
me coronavirus i don't care if i die
that's not no one has that
view of course not
but either we're going to function as a
human society or not
the only other option is what exactly
the total abandonment of human society
but here's the greater point to all of
this i think and uh this cannot be
emphasized enough
that what schools are doing here i mean
what that article i just read to you
it's one long article basically making
the case
that schools are not essential
we um grocery store workers have been
working this entire time
you know uh
we we can think of of of many different
bus drivers and we could think of many
different people
work in public transportation uh which
is pretty which is
pretty damn high risk uh we can think of
many different types of jobs where
they've been going to
to work people working at walmart have
been going to work this entire time
have been granted status of essential
workers
and the interesting thing is there there
hasn't been nearly as much handwringing
over
grocery store employees and the risk
that they're in as it is now over
teachers
and i think part of the reason for that
is that
even though i'm opposed to the
government being able to stand up there
and declare who is essential and who
isn't
and of course every job is essential
at least to the people that are working
that job is essential to their families
so essential in a very real way i don't
like the idea of the government
declaring who's essential and who isn't
but certainly i don't think anyone
disagrees that grocery stores are
essential
and that's that's why there wasn't
nearly as much handwriting because we
all said well
grocery stores need to stay open
and uh you know if you choose to work
for a grocery store then you're going to
go to work and you're going to have a
job you're going to have a salary a lot
of people don't
if you decide that that's too much of a
risk then then you know you could you
can quit that job
but there hasn't really been anyone
there's been hardly anyone arguing that
we should just shut down
grocery stores right because we say we
need it for society
now up until this
most of the people arguing for shutting
down schools up until the coronifiers
they would have been the ones saying yes
schools are absolutely essential they're
even more than grocery stores if
anything we we you know
we have to have schools open kids need
it
there's no way to replace that
educational experience that they get
inside the schools
that's what we've been told for years
everyone who opposes homeschooling
and there used to be a lot of people who
opposed homeschooling
i should know as a homeschool advocate
for years i've been dealing with these
people
and they all said there's no replacing
this you've got to send them into the
schools as the kids
needs it's an essential need that kids
have to go to school and be a part of
that school experience
now all at once it seems like all the
people that have been arguing that for
years are saying
oh never mind actually schools aren't
essential we could shut them down
indefinitely
you know we shut them down for half the
school year last year shut them down for
another school year
they'll be fine you know the kids it's
not gonna it's not gonna hurt the kids
much they'll be okay
and the thing is i agree you know i
agree that the public school education
system is not essential
even more than non-essential it is
oftentimes actively harmful
but i've been saying that for a long
time that's always been my position
i think that parents can step in and
fill the gap and do in fact an even
better job a much better job oftentimes
than the public school system can do in
educating children
when you're educating your own child
nobody knows your child better than you
do
and no one can give your child a more
personalized
um custom customized
education than you can you put a kid
into a classroom with 30 other students
and they go from classroom to classroom
they have a teacher for 45 minutes or an
hour they go to the next one
you know you're putting them on the
factory assembly line and just
and just sending them down the conveyor
belt and everybody has to fit into that
particular mold and all the kids who
don't fit into the mold
are basically abandoned by the system
and have no chance of really learning
anything
that's a terrible way to educate kids
they'd be much better off at home
i believe that
but the point is that most of the people
who who would have
strenuously objected to that idea are
now saying public school system is not
essential and we should remember that
because eventually whenever it happens
you know because whether it's a
vaccine or whatever and they start
opening up the schools again
and a lot of the people that were saying
schools are not essential
we'll go right back to saying oh yeah
there's nothing more important than
education got to get the kids into the
schools
no we can't let them do we can't allow
them to do that we have to remember
what they've been saying and hold them
to it
let's go to our um headlines
before we do i want to tell you about
policy genius you know
saving money is never a bad idea
especially these days but there's never
a bad time to start saving money
every time is a good time to get started
doing it shopping for life insurance
is one of those areas where you could
save a lot of money and uh you know
shopping for life insurance is also an
area where there's a lot of questions
you might ask how much coverage do you
need
which insurance company is the best one
for you how much should it even cost
um and at a time when it's more
important than ever to have life
insurance
the pandemic is making it a little bit
more complicated to actually buy it so
that's where policy genius can help as a
life insurance marketplace backed by a
team of experts policy genius is keeping
track
of all the changes in the market so you
don't have to they'll find you the right
amount of coverage of the best possible
price without the headache
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies in one
place
it takes just a few minutes to compare
quotes um and uh here's the best part
here's the
the highlights take away fifty hundred
dollars or more you could save by using
policy genius
to compare life insurance policies 1500
or more a year
and think about what you could do with
that extra money the savings that you
could uh
could start to to amass so if you need
life insurance but you're not sure where
to start head to policygenius.com
policy policygenius will help you find
the best rate and handle the process
completely
they'll get you and your family
protected and hopefully give you one
less thing to worry about
try it today policygenius.com all right
let's go to
five headlines
[Music]
number one kanye west appears to
actually be running for president
it seems i i admit that comes as a bit
of surprise to me i assume that this was
all a stunt to sell albums which
i'm still not convinced it isn't i think
i think maybe that is what this is but
he did hold an actual campaign rally of
sorts this weekend
he's got petitions to get him on the
ballots in various states
um i don't know what the end game is
maybe the end game is 1600 pennsylvania
avenue
who knows the kanye doubters like myself
it's as if we've already forgotten that
a reality tv
game show host won the presidency in
2016
despite how improbable that seemed at
the time to people like me
in any case the highlight of kanye's
event without question
i think was his very emotional and
compelling
discussion about abortion and he reveals
um some things that i that was new to me
i'd never heard this before i'm not sure
if he talked about it publicly in the
past or not
but he reveals why the issue is so
important to him and why he takes it so
personally watch this
i'm pregnant i say
it's yes going to tell you what was in
my mind she was crying
she said i just came here to talk to her
but it's like oh my god
because i was having my you know the
rapper's lifestyle
so she said she was pregnant
and for one month and two months and
three months
we talked about her not having this
child
she had the pills in her hand and people
know these skills where you take the
pills
and if you take it it's a wrap the
baby's gone my mom
saved my life my dad wanted to abort me
my mom saved my life there would have
been no kanye west
because my dad was too busy
[Applause]
[Applause]
we love you
now kanye has obviously sustained a lot
of criticism recently
when he put out the christian album and
he came you know was coming out in
support of donald trump even though i
guess he's backtracked from that
recently and said
he doesn't support trump anymore but
all of that criticism is was
nothing in comparison to what's coming
to kanye now
because once you start talking about
abortion and especially talk about the
way that he is
that's a powerful testimony not only as
a man who as he says almost
you know almost was never born and his
life was saved by his mother
but he's admitting that he himself
um if it were up to him
would have aborted his child and his
wife stepped in and said no we're not
going to do that now he's looking at his
daughter and is
obviously grateful every day that he
didn't make such a horrible choice
that is that's a very powerful testimony
um to hear from someone a man a black
man
you know and the left cannot tolerate
that
they they simply they can't have someone
going around saying this kind of
thing about abortion their holy
sacrament
so just watch if you thought it was bad
before
you're going to see the treatment now
that kanye gets and it's going to be it
already has been
ugly number two as we get close to i
guess our third straight month of
leftist violence and chaos
there are no signs of it letting up uh
here are just
some examples over the weekend here are
leftists in seattle breaking into
an amazon store to steal stuff
and then we go over to portland there's
riding in portland
featuring the familiar serial arson and
here are some antifa terrorists
trying to start fires in in the city
and it's not just portland and seattle
either let's be clear about that 18
officers
were injured while protecting a
christopher columbus statue
from being torn down in chicago um
and you could see how they were injured
here are the quote-unquote protesters
throwing rocks and bottles and other
assorted
projectiles at the officers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
remember two things though folks number
one first of all
all the people you've seen in those
videos those are poor starving children
who just want some bread
according to aoc they just want bread
that's all
why won't someone give them some bread
that's all they're looking for they're
going into an amazon store looking for
bread i don't think they're gonna find
any there
but that's it these are starving people
who desperately are
they're just committing crime out of
desperation because
they're on the brink of starvation and
they figure the only way to
survive is to throw bottles at police
officers
makes a lot of sense and second um
also remember that even in spite of
everything you've seen there and
everything we've seen over the last two
or three months
we should really be worried about the
real problem the real threat
is that federal law enforcement officers
in scary camo uniforms are
quote unquote abducting people off the
street otherwise known as making arrests
because after that one video that we
played last week of
some police officers in uniform saying
police
went and uh and quote kidnapped someone
and put him in an unmarked van and we're
supposed to see this as some
horrible new innovation by the police no
unmarked vehicles are very common police
have been using them for a very long
time
um and kidnapping someone off the street
otherwise known as
making an arrest that's that's what an
arrest is
are we now saying that arrests have to
be consensual is it
is this a no means no situation where
the person could say no officer
uh i prefer not to be arrested today in
fact maybe
maybe try back tomorrow but i'm just not
in the mood for her for an arrest oh
okay if you don't want to be arrested
then never mind
have a great day and we laugh about it
but that is that is
really actually what the left wants
that's that's basically their vision of
how policing should work
number three reading from the daily wire
it says a pair of doctors in australia
want to do away with terms like
adam's apple and achilles tendon
with one doctor calling them
misogynistic dr
kristen small a queensland specialist
obstetrician gynecologist and anatomy
lecturer
calls for the terms to be phased out
saying that they represent older
generations
i think we have personal choice to
decolonize our language and these
historical terms will fade out
says small she still teaches the terms
known as
eponyms for exam purposes but notes that
there are alternatives for the dead
man's names
she says the century-old anatomical
terms are named after
old men kings and heroes
uh and i guess we gotta get rid of
adam's apple because
it's believed to be named after the
biblical figure of adam okay
of course achilles tendon named after
the greek hero of the trojan war
i don't know why that's sexist exactly
but apparently it is
we have to get rid of that you know this
is another thing that we kind of laugh
about because it's so silly and it is
silly
but there is we always have to remember
with these pc name changes
there's something nefarious under the
surface of this and because it's all
about control it's about controlling
what we say how we speak
controlling the language um it's
something the left has been doing for a
long time and they've been very
successful
it's been one of their most successful
ploys and tactics
let's go to number four well we call
this
this segment five headlines so here is
the headline
claremont 13 year old dies after
experiencing covid19
symptoms this is the headline from
los angeles uh the cbs affiliate in los
angeles
uh that's that's it claremont 13 year
old dies after experiencing coven 19
symptoms
and other outlets like the daily mail
have picked this up and had
almost exactly the same headline now
you read that you think that's that's
obviously horrible
um and you you read through it now i
read the article
it's not until you get to let's see one
two three four
five you have to get six paragraphs in
before you get to this on july ninth uh
mac
the boy's mother took him to get tested
for cover 19
that test came back negative the mother
says his symptoms matched but then the
test came out negative so we were a
little bit confused okay so
what we have here put in the headline
dies after experiencing cover 19
symptoms
uh don't tell us until six paragraphs in
he tested negative for the virus
so what so all we have from this story
all we know
is that this was a child he had coveted
symptoms
which means what fever coughing that
sort of thing
and then he died so what we know for
sure is that it's a terrible tragedy
but that's all we know for sure
and we also know he tested negative for
covert 19. now
uh that doesn't mean he didn't have it
you could get a false negative
that does happen but there's no reason
at all to assume he had a false negative
in fact based on the reporting there's
no reason to assume that his symptoms
had anything to do with his death we
don't know
they said they're gonna do an autopsy we
don't have the results of that yet what
we have the media doing here
is blatantly explicitly
exploiting the death of a 13 year old
child um
for their own purposes for clicks and
ratings and for political reasons too
because they want to scare people they
desperately want to scare people
especially when it comes to there's no
coincidence here
that they're taking this headline and
they they're they're they're reporting
in a you know
in an extremely let's call it misleading
way right when we're in the middle of
debating you know
opening schools or not and trump
obviously is out in favor of opening
them up
the media they're looking for and they
want to
find stories of kids dying of cover 19
and if they can't find it then they're
going to do this which is grotesque and
disgusting and evil
and they know exactly what they're doing
by the way
covid symptoms those are also flu
symptoms
and since we know that flu kills three
times as many
kids in his age bracket why not assume
that it was the flu if we're gonna make
any assumptions at all
you just as easily assume that he died
of the flu or here's a better
case here's a better idea don't make any
assumptions
make zero assumptions wait for the
autopsy to come back and then
you know wait wait for actual
information about what killed this child
number five i have no idea of the
context here but i've seen some people
talking about this on social media
i guess in new york people are getting
this alert on their phone here it is
there's one one person on twitter has a
screenshot says
report of man armed with banjo
there's a man armed with a banjo
somewhere i guess the police are
responding i don't know what's happening
the
details are very sketchy what i want to
say first of all is that the attempts
that have been made to connect me
to this incident are baseless and
libelous i was not involved in this
event
i have no knowledge of it second
though i was not involved let me say
that i understand why this happened
um whatever happened i understand why it
happened
we banjo players we members of the banjo
community we
banjo-ists as we call ourselves
have been minimized and otherized and
stigmatized
and marginalized and dehumanized
and vaporized and
cauterized all the eyes we we
for too long that's happened to us
there's only so much you can take after
a
while
i mean when you hear banjo okay
the word banjo you you hear the the
sound of a banjo the glorious
beautiful sound what's the first movie
you think of
with the banjo right you think of
deliverance this is how my community
has been portrayed on film for decades
hillbilly
backwoods rapists so it's is it any
wonder
that a community which has been the
target of such
degrading stereotypes and prejudices
would would lash out in this way in
whatever way this was
whatever happened can you can you blame
us for communicating our anger and our
sorrow
in a way that gets your attention
i'm not justifying it whatever happened
i'm just saying a little bit of empathy
i think would be
necessary we're gonna go to our daily
cancellation
uh but first you know in the midst of
all this news we've been talking about
ben shapiro has a new book out called
how to destroy
america in three easy steps and uh you
know he really this is a a prophetic
book in a lot of ways because we we're
seeing a lot of what he's
been writing about uh what what he wrote
about in the book
coming to life all around us the book
goes
on sale tuesday july 21st at 6 pm
eastern 3 p.m pacific and ben will be
doing a
virtual live signing event on the day of
the release with your purchase of a
signed book you can write in a question
which
may be read and answered as he signs
your books live on air you can pre-order
your
signed copy and write in your questions
at dailywire.com ben
as far as the book itself you know it
covers two fundamentally different
visions of america that are on the table
right now
one vision is unifying finds our unity
and shared philosophy and culture and
history
the other disintegrates our culture and
our country
in the name of fundamental change um how
to destroy
american three easy steps details how
this alternate world view has gained so
much culture
cultural ground so quickly how has this
happened why is it happening
that's all covered in the book again go
to dailywire.com
ben order your signed copy and join
ben's live signing on tuesday july 21st
okay today for our daily cancellation i
have to issue a cancellation
begrudgingly
not because i want to with no personal
animosity behind it
in fact in performing this cancellation
ritual
i am following the rules and customs of
our modern society i am enforcing the
rules
their rules not my own these are not my
rules
the subject today is a young woman by
the name of morgan bullock
and she was profiled by the bbc recently
uh that profile has gotten some
attention online
let me uh it's about a five minute video
i don't play the whole thing but let me
play just a clip of that for you watch
this
people saying that i shouldn't be irish
dancing because i'm
black and i don't look like most irish
dancers
but i saw it for the first time at a
recital and it was just
the coolest thing ever to me
[Music]
when you went into those irish dancing
classes were you the only
african-american girl in the class
yeah i was always the only one in my
class did that ever have any effect on
you or how did that make you feel
i mean obviously it's hard to miss
someone who's actually their face
matches their legs at the competitions
because you know the
there's like the tanner you like there's
a lot of time yeah a lot of tanner but
it's hard to miss
someone who's african-american i don't
think i ever considered it an issue it
was definitely something that i took
note of
but i had grown up in a predominantly
white area so it wasn't something that
i was uncomfortable about
after going viral with her irish dance
the reaction was
overwhelmingly positive but there were a
few who thought that what she was doing
was inappropriate the negative comments
that people were leaving
under the video what were people saying
just early on like shortly after posting
it some people were saying
that what i was doing was cultural
appropriation just because i don't
look like what you would typically
picture an irish dancer to look like
but i mean so were they saying because
you weren't irish and because you were
not white
that you shouldn't be performing irish
dancing yeah basically that's what they
were saying you were misappropriating
the irish dancing culture i mean my
understanding of the term is that it
means
when you're taking something from
another culture claiming it as your own
without recognizing where it comes from
and that's
couldn't be further from what i'm doing
like it's important for people to
recognize that there's a difference
between appropriation and appreciation
i think people use the term
appropriation without without knowing
what it really means
okay so she's a she's an irish dancer
black woman
uh from where they say virginia now
first of all they didn't show an example
of the
supposed negative comments that this
woman has received but it's obvious that
the negative comments were way way way
outnumbered by the positive which is
good
and let me be clear about this i i agree
with everything she said
um i agree that she's not guilty of
appropriation
i agree that this is appreciation i
agree that if you see a type of dance
you know for example and you like it and
you admire it and you want to do it
that is by definition appreciation and
should be embraced
i also agree that if cultural
appropriation means anything at all
it must mean taking something from
another culture
and pretending that you came up with it
or that your culture came up with it
so if she did an irish dance and like
claim that she invented the style or
something or that it's a style she
inherited from her ancestors or
or whatever then then yeah that would be
i suppose appropriation
but of course she didn't do that and
almost nobody would do that because that
would just be bizarre you know she she
likes irish dance that's why she got
involved in it
and she's not trying to she has no
interest in in trying to
degrade irish dance or or hide from the
history of it she likes it that's the
whole point here
she admires it uh you wouldn't give
so much of your life and so many hours
of of your day to practicing it if you
didn't admire it
um however everything she's saying
and the definitions she's giving even
though she's right
and she's being reasonable none of that
is actually what the left
says about cultural appropriation
according to the left
it doesn't matter if you appreciate the
culture it doesn't matter if you think
that uh it's cool
or or beautiful or whatever else
to do a dance or to take a style or
anything else from another culture
if you are not of that culture is
appropriation
those are the left's rules and since the
left's rules those are the rules of
society
in fact here's an example this is also
from the bbc just to
uh just to frame this here
this is an example also from the bbc a
couple years ago
another thing of another cultural
appropriation controversy
but you'll notice that though the bbc
defended
miss bullock they take a very different
tone here
if you look at this headline prom dress
prompts cultural appropriation row
and then it goes on i'm not going to
read the entire article but maybe you
remember this case
a white white girl high school student
uh in utah decided to wear
a traditional chinese dress to her prom
and she posted pictures because she was
proud of it and she thought it was cool
and you know she liked the style and
everything
and they went viral in a negative way
i mean overwhelmingly negative response
um one of the one widely shared response
from a twitter user jeremy lam
said my culture is not your effing prom
dress
and a lot of criticisms like that and
finally the
uh the girl was forced to take down the
pictures
she tried to say that she didn't mean it
to be negative she was appreciating
chinese culture
but she had to take it down and she
apologized now
if wearing a chinese dress to prom is
appropriation from the chinese
then doing an irish dance and performing
in river dance is appropriation from the
irish
there's no way around it now i know the
way around it
the attempted way around it is um
is is in fact they they
uh in one of the article i think in the
in the bbc
article they say that appropriation is
oftentimes when a dominant culture
takes from a minority culture
but first of all that's just ad hoc
silliness okay you're you're inventing
definitions
as you go along adjusting the terms
uh as you go along according to what it
will be politically useful to you so
that
that's not a legitimate way of going
going about this anyway
but secondly irish culture is not
dominant
or in the majority anywhere um
except for maybe in ireland even though
even there i did you know
it's it's debatable at this point
i and i would submit that black culture
in america is
quite a bit more dominant and has quite
a bit more power in america than irish
culture
i don't think there's any denying that
so no matter how no matter how you slice
it or try to define it
this is appropriation and cancellations
must be handed out i'm afraid
i don't want to do it but those are the
rules
unless of course we want to all admit
that the whole idea
of cultural appropriation is nonsense
[Music]
a culture actually cannot be
appropriated
like even if i were to become a hindu
and and give myself a hindi name
and wear the traditional attire that
hindus wear and i were to celebrate
diwali and other hindu
uh holidays all the rest of it i
wouldn't be appropriating anything from
the people of india
because i'm not depriving them of their
culture by partaking in it myself
this is not a zero-sum game with
cultures a culture doesn't lose
something
just because someone outside of it is is
influenced by it or imitates it
i mean they used to say imitation is
this is the you know the highest form of
flattery
that's all it's imma it's not
appropriation
it is at worst imitation okay
what i would really say is you're
partaking in it it's it's
i would say it's it's more participation
than even imitation but fine if you want
to call it imitation that's fine too
and and not only do cultures not
lose anything by having other people
imitate it
they actually gain cultures gain
influence they gain power they gain
recognition
by being you know quote unquote
appropriated in this way
and this is really obvious what the
irish dance thing okay
you know irish dance traditional irish
dance um
now it's being performed by uh you know
black women in america and it's getting
getting media attention because of that
anyone who's a fan of irish dance
whether you're irish or not
you're not going to see that as a
negative that's great just more
attention more people getting involved
in it you have a young you have younger
generations
more diverse generations of people
getting involved fantastic
great stuff why would anyone have a
problem with that
well it should be the same thing with a
with a chinese prom dress
uh it's just it's spreading the
influence of that culture
more people are getting exposed to it
more people are saying oh this is a
beautiful dress
what could possibly be the problem with
that to have someone seeing a dress
a traditional
chinese cultural dresses like that's
beautiful i want more people to see this
beautiful dress
there's there's no way for a sane person
to interpret that
in in a negative way but of course there
are a lot of insane people in this
culture so it's one way or the other
you know if we don't want to cancel um
this young woman
for for for doing irish dance which i
certainly don't want to
then the only other option is to say
we're going to cancel cultural
appropriation
the whole concept is canceled we're
getting rid of it because it's nonsense
and uh if you like a part of someone
else's culture
and you want to imitate it partaking it
whatever go for it
that's what cult that's that's how
cultures work perfectly fine
and we'll leave it there for now thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton